[Music]  my parents are squatting in an abandoned  building on the Lower East Side they  were homeless for three years before  that which is pretty much how they  raised us this is as real as it gets  kids you learn from living from the  best-selling memoir by Jeannette Walls  it should be a chain divide you lose  your sense of adventure  my dad can be extremely cruel but he  dreams bigger than anyone I've ever met  I can't let you cling to the side your  whole life just because you're scared  and the producer of The Blind Side End  Life of Pi why do you think all of us  ran away from you we were drowning we  ain't like other people get a fire burn  bellies Academy Award winner brie Larson  Academy Award nominee Woody Harrelson  and Academy Award nominee Naomi Watts  you were born to change the world you  wouldn't like me damn like you I'm glad  the Glass Castle directed by Justin  Daniel [ __ ] rated pg-13 August 11th  [Music]  you